[Musique]
on va aujourd'hui parler d'un nouveau
drone qui s'appelle le fadeur qui est
fait par la boîte trendlabs et keith
manière d'une somme toute d'une bonne
qualité alors on n'est pas sûr sur des
drôles hyper puissants qu'ils vont
pouvoir faire des choses de dengue par
contre le produit est très sympa et
tiens on va regarder déjà ensemble dans
un premier temps la boîte voir un petit
peu ce que s'est dit on va acheter un
coup d'oeil aux produits et après on le
fera voler ça c'est la boîte c'est le
fan le fadeur de trendlabs qui est bien
sûr un produit fabriqué en chine mais
qui en tout cas d'être vraiment très
très sympa alors un packaging sympa
voyez le le noir et le jaune ça se tient
le produit on le voit ici d'un petit peu
de tous les côtés il ya quelques
fonctionnalités qui sont sympas le
décollage et d'atterrissage automatique
il mettra son altitude fin de la photo
et de la vidéo en hd
il ya en scrutant wifi à l'appli bien
sûr qu'ils aient pour app store et pour
le bourgueil blais on a une télécommande
sur laquelle on va pouvoir poser un
autre smartphone sur le dessus via
l'application effectivement sur android
ou ou apple et ça fonctionne pas mal
donc on va regarder ça ensemble je vais
vous ouvrir cette jolie boîte alors à
l'intérieur on a le guide de démarrage
les petites informations sur le produit
et d'un sur le produit en lui même alors
dans un premier temps on voit
effectivement ce drone qui est tout
petit ça fait partie effectivement de
cette nouvelle génération de mini drones
qu'on peut faire voler un petit peu
partout qui est très très sympa et ont
souvent à la télécommande
voilà à quoi ça ressemble c'est
effectivement tout petit ça tient dans
la main c'est ça fait penser un peu là à
la taille du spark de dj hi même si
effectivement le les produits ne sont
pas similaires et ne font pas la même
chose
un tout petit produit il ya une carte de
4 gigas qui inclut à l'intérieur pour
pouvoir effectivement bien capter vos
souvenirs en photos et en vidéos une
petite batterie amovible qu'on peut
retirer pour pouvoir effectivement le
chargé qui vient se remettre ici juste
derrière up très facilement
voilà quand on est dans le bon sens ça
marche mieux mais voilà ça marche très
très bien la carte qui est situé juste
ici les protections des hélices on a
quatre hélices un petit emplacement ici
pour venir effectivement le recharger
est ici un bouton de démarrage dawn of
la caméra sur le devant est en dessous
on a un témoin lumineux qui nous ont dit
quand est-ce que kankan la charge est
fait
la télécommande est aussi sympa on n'est
pas sur ce que souvent il ya beaucoup
drones vous pouvez les piloter qu'avec
vos smartphones et c'est vraiment
dommage
avec 7 avec ce drone là on peut vraiment
faire pas mal de choses on a ici une
place qui nous permet de caler notre
smartphone directement sion dessus donc
ça c'est top
les boutons d'altitude pour le faire
tourner et faire pivoter avant arrière
droite gauche ont des règles ici notre
hymne pour pouvoir régler effectivement
bas l'inclinaison du produit est ici on
a des boutons pour prendre des photos
faire pas mal de choses avec est ici un
interrupteur switch off on peut sans
smartphone phare dessus ça permet
effectivement de voir un petit peu ce
qu'on fait voir
voire dès les photos va rejouer le drone
avoir avoir la vue du drone comme ce qui
se fait actuellement et c'est vrai que
c'est quand même plutôt pas mal commencé
il faut savoir qu'à l'intérieur se
produit on a effectivement aussi quatre
hélices de rechange plus un petit
tournevis pour pouvoir les démonter ça
c'est bien
un câble de recharge et ça je ne sais
pas quoi ça sert je regarderai un petit
peu plus tard alors ce que je vous
propose c'est de le poser d'essayer de
faire voler et puis de voir ce que ça
dit tout simplement
[Musique]
alors au final que penser de fadeur
alors le fadeur franchement ça reste un
bon drôle facilement maniable très
facile à piloter on sait plaisir après
il a des avantages et des inconvénients
le vrai avantage de ce drone déjà ça va
être son prix il est particulièrement
pas cher facilement accessible
on est juste un petit peu au dessus des
100 euros donc bon ça c'est un un vrai
point positif
autre point positif la télécommande qui
est vraiment très très facile de prise
en main on peut c'est main facilement
sur on sait que là comme certaines
choses très très facile à piloter
ça c'est sympa il réagit bien c'est un
très bon droit il ya certains
inconvénients siècle faveur à savoir
déjà que c'est un drone qui est léger
qui est pas extrêmement puissant donc si
vous avez du vent que vous normand
d'altitude
vous avez quand même brise qui souffle
ça va vous le décalé il développe pas
assez de puissance pour effectivement
pouvoir à contrer ce petit vent donc si
vous voulez le faire voler vraiment
souvent en extérieur en altitude c'est
pas forcément le produit qui va être
fait pour vous autre point négatif la
vidéo est faite en 720p on ne parle pas
ici de full hd mais 2 hd néanmoins ça
fait job ça fait des bons souvenirs soir
ne se faire plaisir pour android qui je
vous dis au final n'est pas
particulièrement cher donc si vous
voulez un petit drone pour vous faire
plaisir à faire voler dans des endroits
où il n'ya pas particulièrement beaucoup
de vent eh bien je pense que le bonheur
peut être fait pour vous merci en tout
cas à vous d'abord regarder cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à me donner vos
impressions par rapport au test de ce
drone je sais pas peut-être l'avez-vous
déjà essayé ou
avez vous déjà comparé par rapport à
d'autres produits vous mettez tout la
description on en reparle très bientôt
moi je vous dis merci et d'ici là portez
vous bien n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à
la chaîne si elle vous plaît il y aura
toujours plus de high tech de bonnes
infos et plein plein plein de surprises
merci beaucoup à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]